ja ich bin in diesen minuten in der ost
ukraine
und hier wird weiter jeden tag
geschossen ich habe heute morgen an der
front wieder erlebt wie mörser granaten
in einem wohngebiet untergegangen sind
und ich habe erlebt wie verzweifelt
viele welt startet und wie viel angst
vor allem auch die ukrainische soldaten
davor haben dass jetzt die truppen auch
weitere teile der ukraine einnehmen
können was mich da als deutscher
besonders wütend macht ist dass wir
nicht vorgehen
nord stream zwei das haben wir jetzt zum
glück erst einmal ausgesetzt aber auf
der anderen seite gibt es noch viele
viele dinge die wir härter durchführen
konnten zum beispiel endlich sanktionen
gegen putins kinder zum beispiel gegen
putins verwandte gegen alle die putin
unterstützen wir brauchen scharfe
sanktionen gegen regierungsmitarbeiter
gegen minister gegen all diejenigen
jetzt weiter im westen urlaub machen in
st tropez urlaub machen wo auch immer
unter druck machen nein das darf nicht
versagt und gleichzeitig denke ich auch
an altkanzler gerhard schröder oder
weise hat gerade seine ehefrau etwas bei
instagram gepostet und hat behauptet so
sinngemäß dass gerd schröder ja zur
vermittlung bereit seid aber die
bundesregierung das nicht wolle sie
würde ganz viele angesprochen warum
gerhard schröder denn da nicht etwas tun
könnte mittlerweile hat man diesen
instagram post wieder gelöscht ich finde
gerhard schröder müssen endlich die
dinge gestrichen werden die wir
steuerzahler weiter bezahlen unter
anderem sein fahrer seine bodyguard all
diese dinge die verbrecherische politik
von wladimir putin muss bestraft werden
wer einen konflikt lösen möchte jungs
heimat werden wahrheit auch in der
ukraine frieden haben möchte und auf dem
europäischen kontinent frieden möchte
darf sich nicht wieder kettenhund des
weißen hauses serien das soll ich ihnen
auch aus der distanz an ihren ort wo sie
sinn wenngleich es auch dramatisch ist
und ich ihre situation durchaus unter
dem eindruck schrecklicher bilder
verstehe aber wenn wir heute in die
ukraine blicken dann müssen wir doch
einige jahrzehnte zurück gehen verstehen
dass es die vereinigten staaten von
amerika wurden die hier die grenze von
berlin verlassen haben und sich mit der
nato gegen den osten ausgeweitet haben
polen rumänien slowakei tschechien
litauen lettland rumänien slowenien sehr
viele staaten sind in den
einflussbereich der ehemaligen
sowjetunion gerückt und ich verstehe
daher ich heiße keinen krieg gut ich
heiße das blutvergießen nicht gut aber
ich verstehe daher dass putin eine
reaktion zeigen muss denn es kann ja
nicht sein dass atomwaffen
mittelstreckenraketen im vorgarten
moskaus stationiert werden gleichsam
erinnere ich mich an das jahr 1962 wie
der dritte weltkrieg vor der tür stand
weil nikita chruschtschow auf kuba
washington und die vereinigten staaten
bedroht hat damals war das schwer toni
und adresse diesmal ist es ein bruch
schwacher us präsident der um diese zeit
wahrscheinlich schon wieder windeln
liegt und oester und europa österreich
deutschland die eu-staaten frankreich
sind die nützlichen idioten einer nato
politik anstatt dass wir hier in dieser
situation eine eigenständige aus und
sicherheitspolitik vertreten die
bedeutet hätte dass wir frieden schaffen
indem wir die ukraine der ukraine
empfehlen sich neutral zu erklären wie
es beispielsweise österreich oder die
schweiz ist und wie er es europäische
union ganz klare beitrittsperspektive
die nächsten 15 20 jahren auf so etwas
lassen sie uns darauf doch direkt ganz
heime die antworten würde ich sagen es
war ja fast seine staatsmännische reden
hier von einer kreuzfahrt eine antwort
darauf
sei eine sehr verwirrende rede denn man
muss sagen dass natürlich jedes land und
eine bündnisfreiheit garantiert worden
ist dass auch russland damit
einverstanden war das ein und andere
diese freie wahl haben und es keine
gegenwehr gab nein es gibt eine
bündnisfreiheit und jedes eigenständige
land darf natürlich selbst entscheiden
ob es mitglied der nato werden will oder
nicht was die ukraine angeht da muss man
gar nicht so weit zurück gucken man muss
eigentlich nur auf 1994 schauen da
wurden der ukraine nämlich
sicherheitsgarantien ausgestellt und
zwar im gegenzug dafür dass sie der atom
waffen abgegeben haben hat russland und
die westliche welt in diese sicherheits
garantien ausgesprochen und jetzt müssen
wir uns anschaut was gerade passiert
herr gross da gab es zum einen die
aktion der krim 2014 es gab dann die
putins schergen hier wenige kilometer
von mir entfernt wo ich gerade stehe die
bereits einen krieg geführt haben und
jetzt gibt es panzer die mittlerweile
von der russischen grenze in richtung
separatisten gebiet das schon vorher von
den airbus unterstützt worden ist war
das lade ich mir putin fährt eine
aggressive aggressivste politik und er
hat in seiner rede gestern behauptet
dass die ukraine kein eigenständiger
stark sein dass diese ukraine zu
russland gehöre habt ihr die
eigenständigkeit abgesprochen das ist
das was das wirklich grausame ist was
hier passiert und da können sie nicht
kommen und sagen deutlich ukraine doch
mal jetzt bitte anfang neutral zu sein
die ukraine hat 1994 noch einmal ihre
aktion bach abgegeben hat als
sicherheits garantien bekommen und wir
sehen ja was hier gerade passiert ist
und was dieses nato gelaber wusste ich
sagen angeht es ist doch so dass
deutschland und frankreich 2008 bereits
gesagt haben die ukraine an lebens die
nato mitgliedschaft besteht momentan
überhaupt nicht auf der tagesordnung ist
los und zweifelsohne dass putin
aggressiv agiert aber noch einmal man
muss das pudels kern treffen man muss
die ursache treffen man muss wissen
warum er so agiert wenn man mit putin
verhandeln will muss man putin verstehen
nun darf man jetzt vergessen dass die
ukraine als sowjetischer staat wollen da
darf man nicht vergessen dass heute noch
genug russen in der ukraine leben man
darf man nicht vergessen dass österreich
zum beispiel auch verpflichtungen
gegenüber südtirol hat der schutzmacht
dass solche mechanismen immer gegolten
haben und das im übrigen auch zu hören
auf dem zweiten weltkrieg noch immer wie
eine gewisse verpflichtung gegenüber den
südtirolern haben und da muss man auch
verstehen dass der kreml oder russland
putin und noch einmal ich bin weder die
kraft noch der knecht des kreml zu
deppert und bin dass klar wird der nato
sondern der europäer und bin 77 geboren
europäisch sozialisiert in einer
sozialen wirtschaft die bin nicht der
handlanger der billige eines vollkommen
vertrottelten us-präsidenten und auch
nicht jedes jahr putin man muss
verstehen dass putin hier angst hat dass
die nato sich ausweitet und diesmal
direkt vor seine grenze die ukraine ist
der puffer zwischen den nato-staaten und
seiner grenze und daher darf man nicht
vergessen dass er hier auch eine
grenzziehung machen muss mir geht's
jetzt aber nicht darum dass ich ihren
aufwand heute runzheimer in der ukraine
verlängert damit sie blut sehen und ihr
sonstiges berichte schon jetzt darum wie
führen wir diese gerne wiederkommen das
war einfach wie kommen wir es das sagt
aus und wie kommen wir aus der sackgasse
heraus indem die ukraine erklärt und
auch ihre verfassungsbestimmungen liegt
in dem sie eben nicht der nato beitritt
erster punkt und dafür übernehmen wir
europa sicherheitsgarantien für die
ukraine und dafür müsste auch russland
eine souveränität erklärung für die
ukraine abgeben und schluss ist der
zirkus und dann kann sich daher beiden
mit der nato verziehen weil dann hat die
nato hier auch nichts mehr verloren
weil ich lasse ich den ball traten also
etwas was sie dort ernsthaft jetzt den
krieg hier mit österreichischen
beziehungen zu tirol vergleicht und
birnen vergleichen kommen was irgendwie
österreich verkauft nicht nur mit tirol
hat so tief bin ich nicht der
österreichischen politik auch wenn ich
sie dafür interessiere allerdings muss
ich sagen es ist doch so selbst wenn die
ukraine sagen würde sie verzichtet auch
die nato-mitgliedschaft selbst dann
würde putin doch nicht aufhören er hat
gerade drei bedingungen gestellt er
abgesagt usain soll die annexion der
krim akzeptieren er hat gesagt sie soll
am ende der ganzen sache keine nato
mitgliedschaft geben und er hat die
entmilitarisierung der ukraine gefordert
und man darf das doch nicht vergessen
was er vor dieser rede gesagt hat
nämlich dass er sagt die ukraine zu
russland hat der ukraine in wahrheit das
existenzrecht abgesprochen
dann können sie doch jetzt nicht kommen
und sagen es ging hier nur um die nato
und was am ende dann kann uns auch das
egal sein denn es geht doch darum wie
europa tatsächlich gemeinsam mit
westlichen partner das sind unsere
darauf reagiert oder schweiz und andere
haben doch alles versucht und mit putin
diplomatisch ansprechen viel zu viele
aus meiner sicht aber und das ist doch
etwas wo man sagen muss dass wladimir
putin hier der aggressor ist und er
stellt immer neue forderungen an die
ukraine und er will am ende sich das
ganze land ja einverleibt und da geht es
nicht darum diese absurditäten die nato
sei an ihn ran gerückt der situation hat
sich in den vergangenen 10 15 20 jahren
was die ukraine angeht nichts verändert
die ukraine wird nicht teil der nato in
den in den nächsten jahren aber das ist
doch nur ein vorgeschobener grund und
reden sie doch auch einmal über platini
putins lügen was er hier verbreitet dass
die ukraine angreifen würde das sind
pure lügen was er sagt dass osten
unterdrückt werden das sind pure lügen
sie können doch nicht ernsthaft so
argumentieren
wir uns einmal schauen sie ich gebe
ihnen vollkommen recht putin versucht zu
verhandeln putin versucht zu pokern
putin doppelt natürlich auch weil er
weiß dass es am ende eine
verhandlungslösung geben wird und daher
kann man auch die forderungen wie
zugeredet jan der richtige handlung aber
die heimat der währungs heimat keine
angst und wir sehen anzahl herum
kilometer von hier entfernt die in die
ost ukraine fahren das ist keine
verhandlungslösung das ist eine invasion
und das ist ein krieg ja aber wir gehen
davon aus dass die invasion nicht in
kiew stattfinden wird er sicher
präsentiert ja gerade heute noch der
unterschied ja ja ist die oops heimat
wenn er nicht sagen das ist eine
verhandlungslösung die band fakten
heraus werden dann müsste ja schon bei
der realität bei holmes heimat da geht
es um gebietet die quasi auch mit sehr
viele russen die dort ihr leben die
jetzt in wahrheit nicht ich
habe mir deswegen ist es nicht mal die
ukraine wer uns einmalig heute selbst
das für falsch ich halte selbst diesen
einmarsch für euch noch einmal von
wechseln sie mir nicht mit dem knecht
deswegen glück muss ich halt
sie glauben dass bisher diplomatie
stattgefunden hat so die bisher
überhaupt keine diplomatie stattgefunden
das ist ein unangenehmer über rassismus
in bodio monate durch seine vielen alten
ist damit an der bode erklärte schoss
das sind menschen die nicht einmal in
ihren eigenen ländern ernst genommen
werden also warum sollten wir ernst
nehmen warum gehen
wird paul hat ja eine etwas schwierige
position zu bescheid ist wie lassen sich
lange wohl verantworten und sonst glaube
ich wird sie auch schon ganze sache
gehen paul damit du auch in ruhe
antworten kannst wenn du bist ja etwas
sehr schwierigen lage gerade
ich hoffe man hat gehört dass ich gesagt
habe von daher kann ich jetzt nicht noch
einmal alles wiederholen aber es ist so
dass natürlich versucht wurde mit
wladimir putin zu verhandeln im mehrfach
und olaf scholz ist der deutsche
bundeskanzler mehrheit gewählt worden
von daher glaube ich schon dass er von
einer gewissen anzahl zumindest der
deutschen respektiert wird genauso wie
immer noch immer kann man muss es
einfach so klar sagen wladimir putin ist
in seiner eigenen völlig wahnsinnige
welt noch einmal hat der ukraine das
existenzrecht abgesprochen er hat nicht
gesagt bitte geht nicht in die nato dann
ist alles gut nein er hat gesagt die
ukraine ist integraler bestandteil
russland und er hat das ausgeweitet
wladimir putin will die sowjetunion so
wie sie einst zurück haben und das ist
das wahre ziel von ihm und deswegen ist
es wirklich dramatisch wenn man hier wie
ich in dieser situation ist und er lebt
was hier passiert das packten geschaffen
werden dass panzer hier sind dass
wladimir putin das tut was er
angekündigt hat dass es immer noch
menschen oder ehemalige politiker gibt
die ernst hat die schuld bei
weimar aber wie wird das deutsche
selbstverständnis nicht beleidigen aber
sie haben mir vorher nicht aus
ich bleibe dabei leider es tut mir
selbst leid auch für die großartige
bundesrepublik deutschland aber ihre
frau und herr schulz mit 26 prozent
kanzler zustimmung werden heute nicht
international ernst genommen
sie sind in wahrheit leider scheinen
andere ein leben lang bleiben dieses
faktor